per le bighe bene tutti ciao che calino
sempre di poterlo toccare non distolga
stories oggi giocheremo da monger in
realtà virtuale sarà pazzesco infatti
giocheremo domon gas con il visore in
realtà virtuale ridevo avvisare di un po
di cose prima di iniziare a giocare il
gioco è online con altri giocatori
appunto come among normale per cellulare
però in questo caso e conosce i
giocatori che hanno il visore in più per
ovest i giocatori hanno anche il
microfono quindi sentirete le loro voci
i loro che parlano parlano del gioco dei
sospetti ecc
guardi tutti giocano dall'america dagli
stati uniti parleranno tutti in inglese
quindi se conoscete in inglese saprete
sempre cosa stanno dicendo io proverò
tradurli un po di cose marito ma non
riusciamo a tradurre sempre tutto anche
perché dovrò concentrarmi sul gioco e
sul non essere scoperto se sono
l'impostore alcune cose sono un
pochettino diverse dal gioco di a mont
des ma per il resto è uguale anzi è in
3d virtuale belli di voi volete un
secondo episodio in cui gioca da monza
nella realtà virtuale lasciate un bel mi
piace se questo video raggiunge i 20
mila mi piace ci sarà anche un secondo
episodio che non vi seguite ancora su
intendiamo andati a seguirmi lo merita
stories e se volete seguitemi anche su
tutto
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
iniziamo subito la nostra partita
virtuale così come potete vedere qua ci
sono i vari giochi ed ecco qua among us
allora cerchiamo una partita in cui ci
sono poche persone
crediamo che in questa azione sono meno
caspita e sono un sacco di persone oggi
ok stiamo per entrare in among ok e così
qua ragazzi siamo dentro alla lobby di
al mont gas è in realtà virtuale se
vedete altre persone che non hanno la
tuta da astronauti e perché in questo
gioco puoi scegliere tu il tuo avatar
come qualcuno mi sta parlando di sé solo
imbuto altrimenti sentirebbero tutte le
cose che dico e volta quindi ognuno può
scegliere il suo avatar
per quello ci sono anche queste
personaggi strani vedete io sono rosa
stiamo aspettando che inizi di gioco ce
n'è già uno già iniziato come potete
vedere lì nello schermo quindi dobbiamo
aspettare che finisca quel gioco e
iniziare il nostro in realtà virtuale
durante questo che cos'è un cazzo se
voglio posso cambiare colore è lì da
quel computer ma penso di rimanere rosa
e mi posso spostare così ma potete
vedere gli altri che stanno già giocando
nel gioco vedete la mappa di among us
quindi poi possiamo fare da spettatori
al gioco nel frattempo che aspettiamo ad
entrare noi nel gioco virtuale quindi
vedete se qualcuno qua nel caffé tè
tutta la mappa è stata ricreata in
realtà virtuale è davvero bellissimo e
non so descrivervi quanto è bello essere
qua sembra visse qua appunto nella
realtà perché tutto virtuale anche se un
po strano vedere altri personaggi tipo
questo che cos'è quando una banana
questo tipo è un robot e poi le persone
ti parlano infatti io li sto sentendo
che mi parlano nelle orecchie ma io sono
il muto che vuole questo che ci siamo ok
ragazzi hanno finito l'altro gioco gli
altri quindi possiamo iniziare noi il
problema è che in questo gioco di among
us possono entrare
un persone di dieci quindi al momento ci
sono dodici giocatori qua nella stanza
vedete è pieno di banane salutiamo già
quindi devono andare via due persone se
vogliamo giocare perché il limite di 10
persone mettendo tutti parlando dalle
orecchie lo capisco niente perché sono
tutti i quadrati perché non per iniziare
di gioco i ragazzi eccoci qua siamo crew
mail
guardatelo profeti rientri di neve
bellissima gara qualche tre fuori nello
spot di tutto troppo fantastico allora
iniziamo ad andare a fare le nostre
tasse già un'emergenza i miti questi
sono gli altri personaggi dati che
alcuni europa per un po salari allora
per le emergenze meeting dobbiamo
guardare qua vedete possiamo votare qua
io sono lesi su perduto perché di cava
ed un nome tra comuni come stanno tutti
incolpando questo robottino viola
praticamente siccome non sei lanciato
per cui bisogna parlare e dire chi è il
sospetto non so perché mi stanno
indicando spero di mano scrajo smetta
che carino quello che con il vino che il
trenino quindi mi sembra che nessuno sia
decine di donne su un sospetto si stanno
un po tutti parlando sopra a vicenda
chi votiamo forse questo rosso e
sospetto buttiamo il rosso
ok ho votato il rosso speriamo che sia
l'impostore vediamo devono ancora votare
il robottino e
i due alieni questi qua ma questo vola
così in altro
comunque nel frattempo vi faccio un po
vedere in giro
lì c'è una pizza nel tavolo quello che
sto dicendo votate votate votate no di
volta disagio per a temi vettore le dita
nel naso effetti si sta vedendo le dita
linda work has once posso farlo morto
vediamo chi è stato eliminato
non è stato eliminato nessuno non so
perchè lì mi sta indicando andiamo a
fare le nostre tasche guardate che bella
netasq in 3 dic
no no no il posto nei giochi su qualcuno
vedete c'è stato hanno riportato un
corpo ma poiché carino questo piccoli e
noi siamo questo sta volando comunque
sono 5 st incolpando a me ha detto che
sta incolpato governo ha detto primis è
una seduta qua nella volley e quindi che
sono sospetta valorizza lo sospetta però
allora io voto il verde che mi ha
incolpato come si chiama dark meadow
start mista incolpando stato dice non ci
credo perché mi stanno incolpando sanno
tutti cantando non so perché tutti
questi così verdi che punti può
camaleonti non lo so sono tv in un team
da un gruppo di amici perché quello che
lo stone brero che sta nuotando lo so se
sdraiato per terra
il mister sta dicendo che sono sospetta
avete sentito detto york
[Applauso]
no non sono io l'impostore wow
fantastico anche se mi dispiace di
essere buttato stata buttata fuori
avete visto come nella realtà virtuale
essere buttati fuori dalla navicella
messa in prova che stavo davvero cadendo
allora dopo possiamo vedere chi era
davvero l'impostore ed era uno di quelli
verdi che vi stavano incolpando infatti
vedete e possiamo vedere come va la
partita
eccoli sono ancora qua in caffetteria
non so cosa stanno facendo nella
caffetteria ancora ciao stanno salutando
ciao ciao
questo sto dicendo che qualcuno l'ha
ucciso
non so chi forse questo non so questo
bianco davanti a me vuole comunicare con
le mani c'è una banana davanti a me che
mi sta salutando 46 trasformate 1 dogg è
carino comunque più carino e questo
piccolino scarichino certo sono
sicurissimo piccolino
ok stiamo per iniziare un'altra partita
speriamo di non essere impostori ok
siamo crew mete ci sono due impostori
tra di noi corriamo a fare le tasche che
l'altra volta non siamo riusciti a fare
ok abbiamo una sas qua ok questa è
semplicissimo semplicemente cliccato
l'upload operate che bello che le dop in
3d invece qua abbiamo la leva per bene
tutti benissimo che andiamo a fare
qualche altra tusk così vi faccio anche
vedere la mappa tutta in 3d che
bellissima hanno ricreato davvero tutte
le aree no c'è già stato un corpo un
paio vi voglio far vedere bene la mappa
politici un fungo gigante wow
questo è il pulsante per chiamare le
emergency meeting lo vedete chi notiamo
vediamo queste dicono se c'è stato molto
sospetto secondo me il fungo e sospetto
perché è enorme e si chiama apollo ok
votato che si sono ancora 3 4 persone
che devono ruotare nel frattempo
guardiamoci un po intorno c'è un pezzo
di pizza durante uno che calino questo
sito dovuto ciao
vediamo se qualcuno ha votato nel
frattempo loro continuano a parlare
quello che corino sta provando a votare
potreste non ci arriva
manca solo questo che deve mutare sta
chiedendo come si fa a votare
ok ha votato anche lui c'è il fungo
gigante cosa davanti a me è ok nessuno è
stato eliminato il futuro paura ok
andiamo a fare le nostre tasche adesso
guardate qua le altre doc 3d che bene
come potete vedere appunto tutta la
mappa in 3d è veramente fantastico
trovarsi dentro among us qui in 3d
ok devo fare questa task no nuovamente
proprio mentre stavo cosa durata hulk
qualcuno è stato fatto fuori che un
altro di questi camaleonti di verdi
perché sa di colpendo a me non vedo
niente perchè cir il fungo davanti no
non incolpando vedova che io sono
sospetta che ha avuto il rosso che mi
sta dicendo che sono sospetta
[Musica]
mi hanno votato e mi hanno sbattuto
fuori dicendo che sono sospetta vediamo
chi erano
erano i due camaleonti lo sapevo non era
quello rosso che voglio io
guardateci famoso cuoche carino che
calino sempre di poterlo toccare bene a
scappare e di ciao.it girato non penso
che vogliono salutarmi
ok ragazzi siamo nuovamente nel gioco
questa volta siamo nuovamente più mezzi
speriamo che non sia sempre io la
sospetta e che non mi sbattano fuori
andiamo a fare le nostre tasche tesi vi
faccio vedere le altre tasti in 3d che
sono bellissime ha ancora chiamato
l'emergente meeting noi vogliamo
esplorare tutta la mamma di farvi vedere
tutta la mappa in 3d qualcuno chiamò da
da agency meeting perché c'è un robot
che dobbiamo votare non lo so votiamo
questo che appaiono le mutande
ok abbiamo altri due con la tuta di
among us tutti gli altri si scelgono
altri avatar
vediamo se anche questa volta dicono che
sono io la sospetta è stato eliminato
quello rosso non è stato eliminato
l'impostore comunque vediamo se ora
riusciamo a fare in tempo questo sta
facendo una task voglio farvi vedere
meglio la mappa prima che venga
riportato un altro corpo un altro
emergency meeting guardate che bello è
tutto uguale gioco bellissimo qua non si
sono però task da fare dobbiamo andare
qua per fare una tasca non ci credo un
emergente milling stanno dicendo
nuovamente che sono io limbo stare ma
perché non si crei meno votate ma la
vera chicca sempre
eccoci qua nuovamente con i due
eliminati quindi sono state eliminata io
e questo crea weight verde ok ragazzi
ora fa una partita crew weight vitale
viviamo lui come se la cava se anche lui
sarà sempre sospetto lo sbatteranno
fuori ti consiglio di cambiare colore
perché non so perchè ma mi rosa per me
dicevano sempre pingping quindi forse
cambiando colore avrai più fortuna non
sarai sempre sospetto che vediamo quanta
gente
ok io sono giallo vediamo che c'è qui
siamo finite il giallo si sono giallo e
stiamo aspettando o ci sono 30 i
giocatori dobbiamo aspettare che
qualcuno vada via
cosa ci sono banane allora abbiamo
quindi tutti vestiti dal fiume va bene
tranne questo che un vestito strano
tutti quei due c'è anche un mezzo metro
fantasma robot fantasma non sono adesso
una volta io stavo giocando ed è apparso
siren ed io sono spaventata tantissimo
era proprio la china ed in realtà
virtuale immaginate che fa male o no una
cosa piccolissima tutto rosa ok stanno
dicendo che qualcuno deve uscire
altrimenti non si può iniziare la
partita anno a verso il portale per per
far saltare qualcuno fuori va bel salto
io fuori dove sono finito sono finito il
china town mandato ma non sei ne vediamo
hanno aperto un portale sono uscito qui
che uno spirito da un'altra parte che
cattivi
ma ce le truffe c'erano troppe persone è
praticamente lo ha detto gatto portare
qui non per un mondo fantastico
allora il gioco non cominciava io ho
detto vabbè mi stavo annoiando
cos'è questo è un negozio e c'è
all'interno tipo un pappagallino che sta
comprando qualcosa dove sei finito una
realtà parallela sulla realtà virtuale
c'è un cassonetto della spazzatura qui
che si sta muovendo da solo a pochi anni
dalla costa gigante ma sei sicura di
stare bene vitale signora non puoi più
entrare nel gioco among us pro solo tipo
non è intrappolato qua oggi voi non lo
so un edificio stranissimo che cattivi
sicuramente chi ti ha spirito qua è
l'impostore campanello andiamo avanti
guardate un sacco di insegne hawks non
si aiuta mi sono perso voglio andare qui
sulle scale guardate una rana una rana
gigante ma che a me dicendo forse vitale
questo visore che sto facendo avere
delle allucinazioni
ma anche questo è un personaggio e il
bidone della spazzatura che si muove un
personaggio i ragazzi queste erano le
nostre partite in realtà virtuale a me
purtroppo è andata male ero sempre
sospette sono sempre stata sbattuta
vuoti altre partite lasciate un bel mi
piace
ora mi lascia un po a 4 cat linee su cui
applicare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quello che preferite e
buona visione
ciao
[Musica]